In code, to create a camera position,
you use a CameraPosition.builder.
This builder takes the properties that
you've just seen, such as the target,
which is the latitude and longitude.
The zoom that you want, how far you
want to be zoomed into the map.
The baring of the camera,
the direction that it's pointing in and
the tilt of the camera.
When you've set all of these
properties and you build it,
you'll then get a camera position and
I've just called it cp here.
Then if you want to instantaneously
update the map to show the location that
the camera is pointing at with these
values, you call map.movecamera and
you pass it, a camera update
factory.newcameraposition
with that camera position
that you've just defined.
Like I said, this will instantaneously
move the map to that location.
But you may also want to animate
the map to that position
where you'll see a flyover type effect
where you'll fly to the new location.
And to do this,
you'll use animateCamera.
And animateCamera takes the same
CameraUpdateFactory.newCameraPosition
ith your camera position, but it also
has a couple of extra parameters.
One is the time in milliseconds
that you wanted to take to fly to
the new location.
Of course you might want to zip
over there really quickly or
you might want to slow pan up over
the Earth and down to the new location.
You'd specify the time
in milliseconds here.
So if you wanted to take five seconds,
you'd put 5,000 milliseconds in here.
And the callback function gets called
when the animation is complete.
So if you want to execute some
code once the animation is done,
you could put it in
that callback function.
If you don't want to use a callback
function, you can just put a null here.
Let's take a look at
an animated camera in action.